[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
terror
so nick cutter this is an author that
i've talked about before uh nick cutter
is actually not his real name it's
actually his horror-focused pseudonym uh
his real name he's a canadian writer
named craig davidson i think he mostly
writes uh mainstream fiction or literary
fiction uh under his real name and then
he has a couple of other pseudonyms that
he writes different genres under nick
cutter being his horror pseudonym now he
actually made a big splash in the horror
community back in 2014 with his
excellent uh and unbelievably gruesome
novel the troop which i actually have
reviewed on this series uh it was about
like a very small group of uh boy scouts
who were trapped on an island who have
to contend with one of their number who
is like a sociopath uh and also have to
contend with lots and lots and lots of
very very disgusting
killer tapeworms lots and lots and lots
of worms it's it was revolting and it
was also like pretty great
then in 2015 uh he unleashed another
slab of like super grisly horror
uh called the deep now this was
recommended to me by
a listener of the show and when i looked
it up on kindle unlimited it was
available to read for free so i dug
right into it because i liked the troop
very much
and i have to say holy
tap dancing christ
this is one of the most horrifying
things i think i've ever read seriously
the whole vibe of this thing really like
stressed me the [ __ ] out um and i
probably think that scenes from it are
just gonna be kind of rattling around my
brain for the rest of my life probably i
mean there's this is like some pretty
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
i mean the troop was fantastic but
this thing was on a whole other level
and i'm gonna say this one got me good
probably because there are very few
things on earth that scare me more than
thinking about the [ __ ] that's going on
like way way way down at the bottom of
the ocean like no [ __ ] thank you i
don't want anything to do with any of
that nonsense
now i do have a couple of like caveats
before we get too far into it
i'm not gonna lie
this novel homages a lot of other books
and movies and i did see like this got
mostly good reviews but people that
didn't like it i guess maybe they
thought that it was like too much of a
rip-off i don't know if i'd go that far
but or that i kind of felt like maybe
maybe they thought it was like just a
cut-and-paste collage of its very very
obvious influences now i'm gonna say
that i didn't really feel that way at
all um i mean in fiction everything's
been done you know what i mean so you
you just kind of have to do variations
on a theme i could totally see though
like how some readers might think it's
too similar to other works but i didn't
feel that personally but i can
understand how people could now the
blurb on the back of the book um calls
it the abyss meets the shining
which is fairly accurate but
this book the deep also has like
substantial dollops of several other
things uh most notably event horizon
uh sphere
the thing alien hellraiser annihilation
uh stephen king's it there was quite a
bit of that in there and also had kind
of like a healthy helping of
lovecraftian horror like thrown in there
like just for funsies so if the family
resemblance to those other books and
movies is going to piss you off or is
going to you know encroach on your
enjoyment of it then maybe skip it but
to be honest with you
i thought
you know in my opinion that nick cutter
did a great job just taking elements
from all of those stories and combining
them into like this really nightmarish
creation that was you know uniquely his
own
the only other possibly slightly
negative things i can say about it um
i'm not real sure how i felt about the
ending uh which i won't spoil but if
you've read it you probably know what
i'm talking about it's like i i could
have take taken it or left it it's just
like i didn't feel one way or the other
about it also there's kind of a thing
where
there's a really big plot point that
takes up a large portion not only the
book's description um but also like a
lot of the first act but then as the
story goes on it's almost kind of like
you forget like it doesn't really have
any bearing on the actual story really
and i wasn't i don't know that didn't
really bother me that much i'll get into
why later on i'll also note that the
transitions between like the present day
action and the flashbacks which are
numerous it's kind of like because it's
kind of a thing where somebody's in a
situation where they keep where they
keep uh being triggered to like remember
things from their past so it goes back
and forth like you know to the dude's
childhood and all this other kind of
stuff um so the transitions were a
little bit clunky in places i felt like
but that's i mean that's a pretty minor
criticism it didn't really bother me all
that much like i said other than that
like i really enjoyed it quite a bit now
i'm going to warn everyone right out of
the gate animal lovers
uh that the poor dogs in this
now they don't
they die but they don't just die
they go out in a way that is so [ __ ]
horrible
that i could barely stand to read it and
it actually like made me cry so
i guess i mean
in terms of like a horror novel that's
not really a negative in a horror novel
because it goes to show that the author
effectively conveyed horror so
good for you i guess i was just kind of
like god damn it oh my god that bothered
me so much so yeah if you're real
sensitive to like really bad [ __ ]
happening to animals this is
this is pretty terrible it's pretty
terrible like the whole time i was
hoping that
it was that something was gonna like it
was gonna be okay that i was just gonna
like oh no no no it just like got worse
and worse and i was just like i am not
all right like after reading that yeah
okay
so now that we've gotten that out of the
way uh anyway the deep starts by
establishing
that the human race is being slowly but
kind of also sort of mellowly like
low-key being phased out by a weird
pandemic which is known as the gets
which is short for forget
no one knows exactly how the disease
works or how it spreads even
but basically if you get it you develop
these you start developing these weird
spots like on your arms i think it's
just on your arms like around your
elbows like kind of like um like on a
banana skin like that kind of thing and
then you start forgetting things like
just little [ __ ] at first like oh where
are those keys and [ __ ] like that but
eventually like as it goes on your body
forgets how to eat and then forgets how
to breathe and then like from that point
obviously you die
now this plot point incidentally is the
one that i was talking about that's kind
of like set up in the beginning and then
becomes like less and less important as
the story unfolds to the point where you
as the reader and i mean i as the reader
almost kind of forget that the whole
worldwide plague deal is like going on
is the thing
now this actually didn't really concern
me all that much uh for two reasons one
the stuff that was happening like in the
main part of the story like to the main
characters was way more interesting and
way more [ __ ] up than the plague
subplot i guess i can call it and two i
feel like we didn't really need yet
another book that's all about oh the
human race like slowly dying off anyway
so i'm like i was kind of glad that that
that that didn't really factor into the
main part of the story like all that
much so our main protagonist is a
veterinarian
by the name of dr luke nelson
now he has lost his his wife has
divorced him like his wife abby but i
think she also like later on like died
from the gets
now seven years prior and this kind of
like comes back into the story later on
but seven years prior the couple's
five-year-old son i think he's five or
six uh their son zachary
mysteriously disappeared from a nearby
park when luke took the boy out there
after school like they're playing like
hide and seek and he literally like
turned away for like 20 seconds and the
boy like literally disappeared and they
have had like found absolutely no trace
of him like since then and obviously
he's really really [ __ ] up about it
and like and he feels responsible his
wife felt he was responsible all this
other kind of stuff even though it was
just like crazy
like i said he looked away for literally
20 seconds and the kid disappeared
so that's kind of like a little bit of
the backstory
so at the beginning of the book
luke is actually being flown out to a
research station that's way out in the
middle of the pacific ocean uh
specifically right over the deepest part
of the mariana trench
turns out that eight miles beneath the
sea
a bizarre substance that they call
ambrosia
has been discovered
and this stuff
may have the potential not only to cure
the gets like the you know because
there's still like a lot of people left
on earth like not everybody you know
it's it's not like a situation where
because like shit's still like halfway
functioning you know what i mean
so it might not only cure that but it
actually might cure every other disease
that's like ever afflicted the human
species since the dawn of mankind right
now luke's extraordinarily intelligent
like super super genius uh but also like
cold sociopathic [ __ ] of a brother
whose name is clayton he's one of the
world's pre-eminent scientists and he is
actually working down at the ocean floor
along with a couple of other researchers
and they're experimenting with this
ambrosia stuff in the hopes that
eventually they can make it into like a
universal healer because it doesn't just
like cure disease but it also like cures
wounds you know what i mean so it's kind
of like this miracle stuff
so it's kind of established that several
of the you know earth's governments like
different countries governments like
they all collaborated
and they built this thing uh like a
research station way underneath like in
the mariana trench called the trieste uh
and this facility is eight miles
underneath the pacific and there that
because that's where the ambrosia was
found and so they're trying to like
harvest it and isolate it and like
figure out what it can do and how they
can use it and stuff like that so luke
is actually being shuttled down to the
trieste because of this really weird
audio message that um the above
water like a research station got so the
audio message was asking for him and the
message was ostensibly from his brother
clayton
also the scientists down at the research
lab have gone pretty much radio silence
there's just kind of like they can't see
them on the monitors anymore and they're
not communicating with the surface
anymore and so nobody like nobody on the
surface really knows what the [ __ ] is
going on down there um also shortly
before luke arrived
uh one of the researchers name was dr
westlake
he actually came up in one of the like
little pod things that they have to go
like to shuttle people up and down he
came out of there and they opened it up
and he was dead in there and it looked
like he had
basically like cut himself to pieces
like multiple times
you know what i mean so it was like
there was all these cuts and then they'd
like kind of partially healed over and
then he'd like kind of like he'd been
going like doing it for a really long
time and they're just like huh that's
really weird and like when he gets to
the top it's like it doesn't even look
like a human being anymore it just
looked like a [ __ ] yeah it was like a
monstrosity now luke has actually no
idea why his brother clayton would have
asked for him he's like you know uh
these the brothers haven't spoken in
years they really don't get along
and clayton has always viewed his
brother as well as pretty much everyone
else on planet earth with barely
disguised contempt he's one of those
well i'm way smarter and you guys and
like i said he's kind of like a
sociopath like he doesn't really have
any human emotions or anything like that
luke is just befuddled as to like why
the [ __ ] would he
want me here i haven't talked to him
forever and he doesn't need me for
anything so i don't really know why but
luke has to admit that he's curious
not only about
clayton's reasons for summoning him
there like eight miles underneath the
ocean
but also about this supposedly
miraculous substance that he's been
working working with that may like end
up saving the world because like i said
he lost um you know family members to
the guts as well so he's like oh my god
this could be like some big miracle
because they're gonna cure all the
diseases so luke uh accompanied by uh
one of the people that works at the you
know the the upper research facility uh
who is u.s navy lieutenant commander
alice al sykes who's a great character
actually
they kind of go in they get in one of
the pod things and they descend into
this lightless alien depths of the
pacific
and
oh man if you were at all claustrophobic
then this book is gonna trigger you big
time
just i mean
just the thought and like the
descriptions of it the thought of going
just down and down and down and like the
descent takes like eight or nine hours
or something like that
you know and just going down into this
utter blackness that's like super
pressurized so it's like just like
pushing all like all the weight and
everything like that i mean that is
just on its own is like really pants
shittingly scary
but then nick cutter like layers anxiety
upon anxiety and he introduces
essentially what you first think is
maybe like escalating madness into the
whole equation so you don't even have
just this hey we're eight miles
underneath the earth uh kind of thing
but there's also like all this other
crazy [ __ ] going on
so once luke gets down there and gets to
the tries to the state the station
he starts to notice that
all of these terrifying childhood
memories and nightmares and stuff like
that are like coming back and they're
like way more vivid than ever and he's
like starting to see things and hear
things and all this other kind of stuff
and at first there's no way of knowing
whether
his sort of crumbling hold on
rationality is caused by you know maybe
he has the gets like maybe he has this
plague that's making him forget things
or like that his mind is winging out or
it could be
um just the experience of being in this
like intensely isolated environment this
confined facility that could literally
collapse from the immense pressure like
any second like yeah it's made of all
these high-tech polymers and stuff but
you know if somebody goes and punches a
hole in the wall or like the glass
breaks or something like that the whole
thing would just be like crushed and you
wouldn't even know like what hit you so
you know yeah it could be that like i
said very much
an isolating horrible experience that
could cause you to go crazy too
or
could it be perhaps something to do
with the very substance that all these
scientists were put here to study
like is this ambrosia
alive and worse is it sentient is it
malevolent like what exactly is this
[ __ ] and what is it doing to the minds
of the people that are down there uh
studying it you know what i mean so
so yeah this book was
nerve wracking as all get out and it
really i mean the way that it's written
really made me feel kind of every
stifling second of being trapped in this
big [ __ ] tin can
beneath billions of pounds of just this
black merciless water just like crushing
down on you
while at the same time some apparently
alien organism of some kind is it's not
alien literally like it's not from outer
space so i don't want to give that
impression but i just meant alien as in
strange like we don't know anything
about it so this organism is like
rooting through your psyche like looking
for the most ghastly things to show you
to just make you go like completely
gibberingly insane because it can get
inside your head and it knows like what
it knows what to do and what to show you
to
get like the maximum impact you know to
me like it knows what your fears are and
it plays on those so like i said kind of
like stephen king's it in that way
uh this book is also intensely intensely
gross
um lots and lots of gooey body horror uh
you know and a lot like big millipedes
and maggots and
just [ __ ] [ __ ] like the thing where
it's like you know
stuff coming out of people's heads and
just it's crazy like it's crazy uh so
it's definitely not for the squeamish
probably you don't want to be eating
when you're reading it either because
it's pretty [ __ ] gross so i mean if
you're a fan of any of the books and
movies that i previously mentioned
and
you don't mind a story that kind of
takes bits and pieces from all of those
like a you know bit like a magpie and
kind of wraps them all up in a sickening
new skin i guess then this should be you
know right up your alley or down your
trench i guess like as it were that
sounded kind of dirty but yeah um
honestly as great as the troop was i
think i liked this one more i definitely
felt like this one was a lot scarier and
like i said that's probably because i'm
like [ __ ] terrified of deep water and
even if it had just been about a guy
like down in this depths and like
nothing even
you know nothing nothing more than that
was going on it would still be really
scary but then the fact that he's down
there trapped with these people who are
maybe going crazy or maybe being
affected by this substance maybe like
whatever it is and [ __ ] like that so
yeah this was like pretty [ __ ]
terrifying uh i'm still mad about the
dogs but you know what are you gonna do
it's a horror story
and uh i don't know no one's gonna leave
the puppies alone i guess but yeah this
the dogs in this had like one of the
worst paints of like for any animal and
like anything that i could remember so
i'm just like warning you about that
going in but other than that i mean i
had a blast with this one i guess even
though it kind of stressed me the [ __ ]
out and made me like really really i
don't know it just it made me kind of
like uh but then i couldn't stop reading
it at the same time you know what i mean
like it was
like watching a slow-motion car crash i
guess it was kind of like that but yeah
i really really liked it a lot so if you
have kindle unlimited you can actually
read it for free
and if you've read it let me know what
you think about it and i've read the
troop and i've read this one now and i
know nick cutter has like a few other
books as well so if anybody wants to
recommend any of those it would be a
while like before i got to it because i
like to kind of spread the authors out
and everything but let me know if any of
the other ones are are really good or
worth reading and maybe i'll review one
of those in the future and that will do
it for this tomes of terror i will see
you guys on the next one bye